When you're working with an actor as talented
as Joaquin Phoenix, you learn to expect and
welcome the unexpected.
“Haha.”
In a wide-ranging interview with Slashfilm,
Joker cinematographer Lawrence Sher offered
some insights into one of the film's most
intriguing scenes.
Basically, no one knew it was coming.
We're going to be discussing a few important
plot points here, so consider yourself warned:
if you haven't seen Joker yet, there's going
to be a handful of potential spoilers ahead.
During the scene in question, Arthur Fleck
is clearly struggling in his own mind as he
rattles around his kitchen, unable to sleep.
He begins obsessively cleaning out the contents
of his refrigerator, and anyone who's ever
suffered a bout of insomnia will undoubtedly
feel for him up to a point, anyway.
Later on in the scene, something entirely
odd happens: Once the fridge is emptied out,
Arthur crawls inside, shuts the door behind
him, and... well, he just stays in there.
It's a unique and entirely brilliant way to
shine a light on the inner workings of Arthur's
tortured soul.
And Phoenix reportedly totally improvised
this highly memorable moment.
As Sher tells Slashfilm,
"When he climbed in the refrigerator, we had
no idea he was going to do that.
We set up two camera positions, and Joaquin
just thought about what he would do if he
was a massive insomniac.
Again, we lit it so he could go anywhere,
and the first and only time he did it, we
were mesmerized.
I remember thinking, 'What is he doing?
Did he just crawl in the fridge?'"
The answer to that question is: Yes, he most
certainly did.
And of course, the shot was so utterly bizarre
it remained in the final cut of the film.
Phoenix was given a massive amount of creative
freedom as he developed his interpretation
of the character … and that creative freedom
proved to be the key to Joker's success.
Sher says his biggest fear while shooting
was inadvertently interfering with the actor's
process.
In fact, during the early days of Joker's
shoot, Sher confessed he was rather intimidated
by Phoenix… and really, who wouldn't be?
“Haha.”
Sher says he did his best not to step on the
actor's toes:
"In the beginning, I didn't really talk to
him that much, but he actually broke the ice
first.
He apologized, saying, 'Sorry, I know I'm
acting a little odd, but I'm just trying to
do this thing.'
I went, [...] 'Please keep doing whatever
you’re doing because it’s fantastic.
If you never talk to me during the rest of
this movie, I’m 100% cool with that, too.'
I didn’t want to get in the way."
But their working relationship changed significantly
during the shoot.
Sher reveals that,
"Once we started shooting scenes with him
as Joker, Joker's confidence meant Joaquin
was opening up more to me, off screen.
Joaquin started watching the dailies to see
what I was doing and we started talking more.
By the end of the movie, it was a much more
open conversation, in ways we could serve
each other."
A surprising amount of Phoenix's improvisations
wound up making it to the screen and many
of those spontaneous moments involved intensely
disturbing dancing.
For instance, the sequence in the bathroom
was only scripted up to a point: Phoenix knew
that Arthur had to hide his gun and wash off
his makeup but the rest was very much left
up to the actor.
Director Todd Phillips previously revealed
that the scene that features Arthur dancing
and strutting down a long stone staircase
wasn't originally in the script, either.
The memorable moment came about as Phoenix
found new ways to demonstrate the evolution
or devolution of his character.
As Sher explains:
"We just [...] let it happen, which became
a major part of how we did a lot of things."
Well, it was clearly a winning strategy.
As Entertainment Weekly reported on October
25th, 2019:
"Joker is now the highest-grossing R-rated
film of all time."
It seems like great things happen when you
stand back and let Joaquin Phoenix work his
magic… his creepy, creepy magic.
“Haha.”
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Joker
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.